hi
i'm euna kravitz a developer advocate on
the chrome team focusing on css and
devtools
i'm really excited to chat with you
today about what many regard as the
future of web styling
css houdini houdini is an umbrella term
that describes a series of
low-level browser apis which make it
easier for authors to
access and extend css by hooking into
the styling and layout process of the
browser's rendering
engine this means that developers now
have much more control
and power over the styles they write for
example
instead of waiting for a browser to
implement an angled borders
feature you can write your own paint
worklet apply it to both borders and
clipping
and get an effect just as you would with
a rounded border radius
instead of waiting for a browser to
implement masonry you could implement
a layout worklet to imitate this
browser-based implementation
or you can use an existing one and
beyond workloads houdini enables more
semantic css with the typed object model
and enables developers to define
advanced css custom properties
with syntax default values and
inheritance through the properties and
values api
today i'm going to be focusing on the
css paint api
which is supported in all chromium-based
browsers is partially supported in
safari
and is under consideration for firefox
however don't let this native support
discourage you
because with the css paint polyfill
created by my teammate jason miller
you can still get creative with the
houdini paints api and see your styles
work across all modern browsers
so let's focus on the css paint api
today
this api enables developers to define
canvas-like
custom painting functions that can be
used directly in css
as backgrounds borders masks and more
in the angled corners example i just
showed it's being used as both a mask
and a border to draw the border as a
border image and mask the element to
prevent
click interaction effect overflow there
is a whole
world of possibilities for how you can
use css paint
in your own user interfaces to make
working with a paint api and other
houdini worklets a little easier to
explore and consume
my team puts together a resource called
houdini.how
it's your all-in-one go-to for css
houdini worklets and information
a congregate library and a reference
let's check it out you can learn all
about css houdini itself with links to
further reading on the about page
here we list all the houdini apis with
some really great links for further
reading and if you're interested in
exploring these a little bit more
there's also this link from is houdini
ready yet where we have
a list of all of the browsers the w3c
spec and links to
both the spec drafts recommendations
for pain api for example it is in
candidate recommendation state
and also the level of support and
whether it's in development under
consideration
whatever is going on with houdini this
is a great place to check that out and
get that information
on the worklets page you can browse
various paint worklets and play around
with different values
to make sure they fit into your brand so
here is just an inspiration page
where you can see some of the
possibilities here using it as a
border using it as a background you can
make some like really cute little
confetti or you could make it really big
this is just another example of how you
can use it
i have one underlined when you could
have many underlines so this is an
example called extra underline you could
change the width the spread
again the color there's an example of
reverse border radius
where instead of the border radius
coming from the inside out it's doing
the opposite it's creating this clip
which i think is cool because it reminds
me of vintage stamps
or like tickets so i think that one's
neat there's also this powdered gradient
you could change the direction
the color you could really play around
with it i like it in white because it's
kind of festive
there's also the sparkles example you
could change the number of sparkles
the hue so you have sparkles of every
color the
height and width of the sparkle so it's
changing the size and the weight so you
can start to
really play around with these sparkles
there's also that angled corners example
so here
you could make all these corners
different sizes and start to explore
what that might look like and change the
weight of this as well
there's the static gradient and i think
this is really fun because the more you
increase the gradient size
the more you're sort of pixelating it
and it reminds me sort of of like a
little roaring fire especially as it's
re-rendering and animating with this
randomized function so i think that
these are pretty neat
as i mentioned earlier despite native
implementation these all
work cross browser thanks to that
houdini paint polyfill
so have no fear and feel free to get
creative with css houdini
and when you've found the right worklet
that you want to use or expand upon in
your own applications
there's a few ways that you can use it
and implement it into your build system
so the usage page here will show you how
to quickly get started with a prototype
we recommend using
unpackage so just calling it the paint
worklet directly and registering it to
your application
but when you're using it in production
environments you'll likely want to
manage the worklet in your file system
here we have just in a code pen
this example with the confetti
worklet this is called extra confetti
what i'm doing is i'm directly
adding it to my system with
css.paintworklet.ad module
and i'm getting this cdn link i'm also
including the
polyfill script and i'm using unpackage
to manage that as well
this is just a really quick way to get
started and the way that you get that
link
is if you go to the worklets page this
right here the cdn link
you could just copy link address and
there you'll have it
so let's go back to this example from
there we can then update the css so here
we have a few
of the values they will have fallbacks
and defaults
but you can update them to make sure
that they look like you want them to
and you could really start to play
around here now another thing that you
can do is animate this stuff so here is
just an example of
a keyframe animation in css that's just
going to change
the number of confettis from 60 to 65
and this will enable us to re-render
this and create this sort of animated
effect
so here let me just quickly create an
animation i'm going to call confetti
let's say 0.5 seconds let's say infinite
and
linear and then once i do that this will
now
start to animate and we'll see just this
little playful
animation of confetti just kind of
playing around on this page
if i wanted to change this worklet again
i could just go and copy the cdn link
if i wanted to change it to sparkles i
could just copy that link address
bring it back here and then create this
sparkle effect instead of the confetti
effect
now when it comes to working in more
production environments
you'll likely want to manage these
workloads yourself and in this case you
can install them via npm
so if i check out this workload page
let's see what workloads we want to use
um this static radio booklet i think is
pretty cool especially
as i mentioned in these wider sizes so
i'm just going to copy the name here of
the npm worklet which is the name that
we have
listed and go to vs code where i
have the create react app baseline sort
of just loaded up here to play with
and now i'm going to npm install this
worklet
as well as the css paint polyfill
and i want to make sure that i am saving
it to my local dependencies
so now npm is going to download this and
register it add it to the package.json
and from there we'll be able to
reference houdini static gradients
and css paint polyfill we're also going
to be using a file loader for this
this way we'll be able to separate the
worklet file and keep it individual and
not mixed in with the rest of the
javascript
so if i check the package json we can
now see that the css paint polyfill and
houdini static gradient have loaded
i can go to my app.js and reference them
so let's first import the css paint
polyfill it autofills because it's
reading it
and then let's import this worklet url
as
a variable so let's do import workload
url from and here i use the file loader
and i am calling houdini static
gradient now we'll be able to reference
the workload url
when we register the worklet so i'll do
css.p
module and here i can call worklet url
so we are now registering the worklets
into our file and our application which
is great
but we're not going to see anything
until we first start the app
but secondly we have to go into the css
and add it in our css
so we have this app started it's loading
here for the first time so it takes a
second
and there is the react app up on the
page so let's go into the css
and let's change this app header
from just this blue background color
which we see here
to having a cool static gradient
background so let's adjust
this file here and we'll add the
paint and we'll call static gradient
and let's do a static gradient on top of
the color this is no longer a background
color
it's a background and let's also change
the static
gradient size so this is a custom
property
it's at a gradient size i like that 10 i
thought it looked
cool so i'm going to hit save now i'm
going to open it here and
there we see that we have this static
gradient background
now being added to our ui which is neat
but this is also really loud so we can
open up dev tools and start playing
around with this
there was another variable called static
gradient color let's just set it to red
really quickly to debug it so now we
have this little
box that pops up and here you can use
all of these neat dev tools
to find the right color and effect i
think something a little bit more
subtle like this could be nice i'm just
going to copy
this hex code open up my vs code again
and i
am just going to add that variable so
static radiant size let's update this
to color and just paste the hex so now
when i open this
we see this static gradient background
i'll just refresh the page
to show you that this is going to render
in the
custom properties that we updated so i
also wanted to quickly show you that
this will work
in firefox here i have firefox pulled up
and in safari so i'm just going to open
this up
in safari as well and drag this into
view and here you could see that we have
this css houdini paint worklet effect
working across browsers with the css
paint polyfill doing a lot of the heavy
lifting
this is also a community driven effort
so we're looking to add your
contributions to our worklet library too
if you have a houdini workload that
you've built or you want to play around
with houdini
this is a great opportunity to do that
please feel free to submit a pull
request and we'll be sure to get it on
our page
the contributing instructions are in the
github and also linked below
and worklets aren't the only thing you
can submit you can also submit a
resource
so here on the resources page you'll
find
a variety of different resources like
articles
editor drafts web docs and tutorials
there's some really great
examples and demo sites so
if you find a great article or write one
yourself
feel free to submit it we'd love to have
those as well thanks for watching this
video on css houdini and the css paint
api
it truly does open up a world of
possibilities
and hopefully houdini.how can help you
discover some of those possibilities
if you've been inspired by something you
saw in this talk please let us know and
contribute your own ideas to houdini.how
whether they're worklets that you've
built or great resources that you've
come across
i would love to see them thanks again
i'm yuna tuning out
[Music]
you